من الف عام هذه المراسم تجرى هناك جزء
عصري لهذه العمليه مثلا تم اشراك عدد من
الاساقفه من خارج بريطانيا من دول
الكومنويز من الشرق الاوسط تم ايضا تعديل
القسم يعني يدخل جميع الاديان وليس الدين
المسيحي تم ايضا اشراك كافه مكونات
المجتمع البريطاني لانه مثلا رئيس الحكومه
في اسكتلندا مسلم رئيس الحكومه في
بريطانيا من جذور هنديه
تم تعديل الموسيقى ايضا استخدمت بعض
الموسيقى التي يريدها الملك تشارلز
التعديل بالحضور دعي الى التتويج ملوك
وملكات مع انه هذا لم يكن العرف
والبروتوكول ولكن
بالغالبيه العظمى من برنامج التتويج
بامكاننا القول انه نحن نشاهد تاريخ تاريخ
عمرو مئات سنوات
بالفين وثلاثه وامام عدسات الكاميرا الان
عاد الملك مره اخرى والملكه ربما لالقاء
التحيه مجددا على يعني الاف المحتشدين في
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن وهذه الصوره
للملك تشارلز الثالث
وزوجته الملكه كاملا وهما يلقيان التحيه
من على شرطه قصر باكينغهام القصر الملكي
عادا الى تحيه
الجماهير ايضا والمحتشدين اسفل القصر من
شرفه باكينج هام كما نشاهد امامنا في هذه
الصوره وهم وهما يرتديان طبعا
تاج تاج الامبراطوري على راس الملك تشارلز
الثالث وتاج الملكه ماري على راس
الملكه كاملا وهي التي تخرج الان مره
ثانيه من الشرفه الى داخل القصر الملك
تشارلز يعيد التحيه على الجماهير التي
احتشدت هو عاده مره اخرى بعد ان خرج القى
عليهم التحيه ايضا كذلك وبهذا تنتهي مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملك المملكه
المتحده باغلاق هذه الشرفه الشرفه قصر
باكينغهام وعودته الى القصر
لمتابعه ربما احتفالات ايضا ستكون في
القصر مع عائلته لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات